hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about the pre and
post-workout meal myth that's right you
heard me right it's a myth now I know so
many people have told you you need to
eat before the workout or after to
basically replace your glycogen Reserve
or build more muscle mass so let's talk
about each one in depth
number one what is the glycogen reserve
you have a certain storage of sugar in
your muscle so glycogen is the storage
of sugar it's in the liver it's also in
your muscles okay it's not a lot if you
were to work out it's going to be tapped
out in about a half hour okay and then
after that you're going to be burning
fat so why in the heck would you ever
want to eat anything sweet before during
and after a workout right that doesn't
make sense because if the goal is to
burn fat then we have to burn off the
sugar before we get to the fat because
that's how the body works so everything
after half hour is all sugar then after
that is fat-burning okay so the other
thing is that if you were going to eat
high concentrated protein like whey
protein the more concentrated that
protein is the more it will also trigger
insulin so a whole egg with fat has much
less response for insulin than
concentrated protein whey protein powder
okay so every time you consume more
concentrated protein you're stimulating
insulin what does insulin do it stops
fat-burning completely so every time
you're doing the protein you're actually
raising insulin in fact every time you
eat you stimulate insulin so why would
you ever want to eat around your workout
see the whole goal is to use exercise to
stimulate metabolism to then tap into
the fat reserves that you have and make
your own fat the meal that you're eating
not the dietary meal so I recommend not
eating anything before during and after
a meal now the other point is you need
to eat protein to build muscle mass now
muscle mass that what you ate right
before the workout or after
it's going to take at least 24 hours to
be digested go through your liver and
end up in your muscles okay sometimes
longer so if you have this idea that
that protein shake is really going to
your muscles it's not it's being
digested and it takes a long time for
that to go into the muscles so you
really don't need protein around your
workout to build muscle mass it's the
meal that you ate yesterday that's going
into the muscles not during or after the
workout all right and also if your liver
is overloaded with too much protein you
won't end up in your muscles so our
bodies do really good with with the
muscle building if that liver is healthy
if you don't overload it and you have
all the trace minerals that help with
the with the building of the muscle so
what we want to do is we want to avoid
insulin because insulin nullifies growth
hormone so take a look at this when you
exercise you induce a stress event that
breaks down your muscles it burns up
sugar in the muscles and then you're
going to eventually stop and then your
body is going to recover during the
recovery process is where your digestion
is occurring where your body is building
back up where it's using fat so if you
eat during this process you are going to
slow down your benefits of weight loss
and muscle building and there's some
exceptions I'll get to that so the point
is that the benefits of exercise
actually occur 24 to 48 hours after you
workout in the deep sleep so a much
better strategy would be to focus on
getting a better sleep and not eating
anything before during and after a
workout okay now the exception is if
you're an athlete the exception is if
you workout twice a day and you're a
huge body builder the exception is if
you're doing marathon or long-distance
running the exception is that let's say
you you're a diabetic and you're having
massive blood sugar fluctuations okay
I'm talking about the average person
who's trying to lose weight okay
so in summary we we want to stimulate
growth hormone growth hormone is the
main fat burning hormone that's
activated by exercise when you eat any
food for that matter especially high
concentrated protein or sugar you're
going to in spike insulin insulin will
then block growth hormone it's a
dominating hormone and you'll notify
growth hormone so therefore you don't
get the effects the muscle building you
don't get the facts of lean body mass
okay it doesn't burn fat so growth
hormone is triggered by exercise sleep
and hypoglycemia so we want to exercise
to tap out our sugar reserves creating a
lower hypo effect of our sugar
hypoglycemia a fact not a bad
hypoglycemic but just a lower blood
sugar to keep this growth from when
active so we can really benefit from
that workout ok so I hope this tip helps
and I just want you to get the truth
about this topic right here so go ahead
apply this and I will see your comments
below